[Musique]
et si le design avait le pouvoir de
rendre l'humanité éco responsable
je suis vraiment heureux d'être ici avec
vous ce soir parce que j'avais très
envie de vous partager cette réflexion
en fait ça me travaille tellement depuis
deux ans que j'ai même fini par monter
une boîte sur le sujet
mais pour que ça ait un petit peu de
sens pour vous je vais commencer par un
sondage très simple
lever la main si vous pensez que l'éco
responsabilité correspond à un enjeu
majeur aujourd'hui
c'est assez unanimes tout le monde a
levé la main mais maintenant je voudrais
savoir qu'ils pensent que l'éco
responsabilité correspond à un enjeu
majeur est également n'a pas mangé de
viande depuis trois mois et fait son
propre compost à la maison attention on
n'est pas dans du coup mes dents du et
qui peut répondre oui à cette question
ah bon je pensais pas mais qui a
vraiment personne
pourtant voilà c'est ça être vraiment
éco responsable et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a à peu près
tous conscience que c'est crucial
aujourd'hui mais soyons honnêtes nous
sommes de manière générale loin d'être
les bons élèves de ce sujet et je
m'inclus largement dedans donc rassurez
vous vous n'êtes pas des seuls
trois français sur quatre déclarent
avoir envie de changer leurs habitudes
pour aller vers plus d'éco
responsabilité
c'est à dire qu'ils veulent adopter les
bons comportements au quotidien pour
être davantage en phase avec le
développement durable on assiste un tel
engouement aujourd'hui pour le sujet que
l'environnement est même devenue la
deuxième préoccupation des français
juste après l'emploi
seulement entre ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on
fait ça pourrait presque ressembler un
programme de campagne présidentielle
on dit qu'on fera et puis on fait pas
toujours
alors c'est quoi le problème comment ça
se fait que si peu de gens soient
vraiment éco responsables alors qu'ils
sont pourtant si sensible au sujet
je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote
moi il ya deux ans l'éco-responsabilité
ça me paraissait une montagne j'avais
l'impression que quoi que je fasse de
toute façon ce serait jamais assez avant
je pensais même que devenir
éco-responsable c'était vivre dans une
cabane au fond des bois prendre une
douche par semaine maximum
ou bien que c'était dormir dans mon
petit matelas de seconde main en coton
bio vegan recyclés
et vu que j'étais clairement plus
attirés par la dernière collection zara
que par ce genre de caricature je
faisais rien du tout
vous allez me dire ok donc qu'est-ce qui
a changé depuis
en 2020 j'ai une crise existentielle en
mode la bobo parisienne qui
s'interrogent sur les risques
environnementaux du nutella vous
visualisez un petit peu l'image
et ça a commencé par ce genre de petites
réflexions et s'est très vite devenu une
prise de conscience plus globale
j'ai commencé à me sentir tellement
étouffé par toutes ces choses superflues
qui encombrent et mon quotidien et mon
appartement
que je me suis mise à vouloir revenir à
plus de simplicité dans ma vie et de
manière assez naturelle je me suis
retrouvé dans une démarche éco
responsable
et là ça a été un énorme déclic
l'éco-responsabilité douche en
profondeur à notre rapport au monde et à
nous mêmes le chemin pour y aller dans
nos correspondre pour nous ne ferons
juste pas partie du voyage
tout le monde nous dit il va verser il
faut faire ça ne mange plus ils ne
voyagent plus là mais toutes ces
fonctions ne nous aide pas rendre cette
démarche adaptée à nos peurs à nos
préférences bref à notre identité
face aux enjeux environnementaux actuels
on a besoin la terre a besoin que le
plus grand nombre adopte de la démarche
éco-responsable et pour que ce soit
vraiment le cas il est indispensable que
chacun puisse s'approprier les enjeux
communs pour en faire sa propre
expérience
alors par chance lors de mon épiphanie
existentielle je faisais un master en
design où j'ai baigné dans ses concepts
jour après jour et justement la magie du
design c'est de concevoir un produit ou
une expérience pour qu'elles soient en
adéquation avec les besoins les valeurs
et des modes de vie des êtres humains
alors au lieu de vouloir changer les
gens pourquoi ils ne se connaissaient
pas plutôt de changer la façon dont son
horaire est le problème
et si le design était la clé pour rendre
l'humanité éco responsable
alors attention le design c'est pas
juste une chaise style est conçue par un
artiste excentrique
le design c'est une manière de penser
c'est l'art et la science de rendre des
choses désirable et agréable par exemple
ce que vous voyez là c'est le cirque tel
que l'a réinventé le cirque du soleil
parce que bon faut pas oublier quand
même que le circuit encore quelques
temps et même encore maintenant c'était
plutôt ça
le cirque du soleil c'est l'illustration
parfaite d'un concept en déclin qui est
redevenu désirable grâce au principe du
design ils ont transformé l'expérience
vécue on va pu voir en simple cracheurs
de feu on participe à une immersion je
dirais même un voyage dans l'univers
esthétique et poétique
qui aurait cru un jour qu'un spectacle
de contorsionnisme allait faire autant
d'entrées qu'un concert de céline dion
et puisque le design est une manière de
penser on peut l'appliquer a
littéralement n'importe quel sujet alors
il y en a un qui l'a bien compris et je
vous épargne ici l'exemple classique de
steve jobs je vous parlais d'un exemple
plus récent
andy roddick ont
donc voté je pense que vous avez
sûrement jamais entendu ce moment là
on dit pudiquement c'est le fondateur de
dead space et et space c'est
l'application qui a révolutionné la
pratique de la méditation de ça
à ça
grâce aux dizaines ils ont fait une
pratique ancestrale complexe à apprendre
pratiquée par un groupe assez restreint
de la population une expérience ludique
et accessible à tous
le design à trois pouvoirs
le premier c'est de créer autour d'un
concept un univers qui va susciter des
émotions en nous alors cet univers il
peut se matérialiser par le logo les
couleurs les aspects visuels le contenu
la façon dont on va raconter l'histoire
95% des décisions que prennent les êtres
humains se font de manière émotionnelle
et puis l'émotion est positive plus elle
va susciter l'engagement
à votre avis pourquoi google change son
logo chaque jour elle c'est pas parce
que leurs graphismes on y entre deux
parties de baby-foot 1
cette stratégie elle a pour but de
susciter un sentiment d'étonnement et en
même temps de joie qui va ancrer google
dans la mémoire de l'utilisateur et lui
donner envie de revenir
maintenant si on analyse un petit peu
l'univers de l'écologie qu'est ce qui se
passe dans notre inconscient
on remarque que l'imaginaire collective
est très souvent remplis d'image de
centrales à charbon ou d'ours polaires
sur un bout de banquise
l'écologie est le plus souvent relié des
émotions négatives et anxiogène elle est
rarement connecté au quotidien et aux
besoins immédiats des individus
les messages qu'on voit passer dans les
médias sont souvent très techniques est
alarmiste et même s'ils sont essentiels
et qu'ils doivent être entendus écoutés
le vt qui génère de la peur est la peur
est une émotion qui paralyse et qui
créent de l'inertie
par exemple lorsque les marques ou les
institutions publiques parle
d'environnement elles ont tendance à
utiliser du verre
la science des émotions par les couleurs
nous montre qu'il est plus puissant de
montrer une couleur pour l'émotion
qu'elle génère plutôt que pour le
concept qu'elle évoque
alors plutôt que d'utiliser du verre
parce que c'est la couleur de la nature
pourquoi est ce qu on utiliserait pas
plutôt du jeune pour susciter la joie et
enthousiasme ou du orange pour stimuler
la créativité
vient ensuite le deuxième pouvoir du
design on l'a vue permet de créer des
émotions spécifique mais son deuxième
pouvoir c'est d'orienter voire de
totalement modifier nos comportements
cet objet je pense que vous le
connaissez tous dès sa sortie en 2007
nous avons quasiment tous adopter
l'iphone pour en faire un objet familier
presque intime du quotidien quinze ans
plus tard je pense que c'est difficile
de trouver quelqu'un qui n'utilise pas
son téléphone portable avec le tactile
et en faisant ce geste là
ce concept de standards qui s'applique
naturellement à tous c'est ce qu'on
appelle le domine ce design le design
dominant d'un secteur
si apple a réussi à imposer un nouveau
dominé design pour le téléphone portable
et modifier autant nos comportements
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne serait pas d'en
créer un pour l'éco responsabilité
on l'a vu le design permet de donner des
émotions spécifique de modifier des
comportements mais son troisième et je
dirais son plus grand pouvoir c'est de
placer l'humain au centre de tout
avec 200 millions d'utilisateurs netflix
et l'acteur qui a révolutionné la façon
dont on consomme les contenus
audiovisuels et sa grâce à l'hyper
personnalisation
par exemple ce que vous voyez là
c'est la page d'accueil netflix de mon
copain des couleurs assez sombre des
titres d'une spécificité incroyable film
pour amateurs de jeux vidéo ou encore
série post-apocalyptique
et ça c'est le mien des tons beaucoup
plus doux et entre notting hill et love
actually on n'est plus vraiment sur une
ambiance post apocalyptique
la personnalisation chez netflix elle va
tellement loin que les designers créent
plusieurs vignettes pour un seul et même
contenu donc là c'est ce qu'on voit avec
la série strangers wings est en fait ils
vont pousser l'une ou l'autre des
vignettes selon le profil de la personne
qui est en train de regarder
l'approché coresponsable elle l est pas
personnaliser elle a même tendance à
nous considérer tous égaux on nous
demande d'agir vite avec la même envie
et les mêmes moyens
le fait est que nous sommes tous uniques
et nous avons tous nos propres moteurs
pour changer
certains vont se motiver à changer leurs
habitudes pour leur santé dot pour être
de meilleurs citoyens d'autres encore
pour faire des économies à la fin du
mois
et toutes les alarmes du monde auront
beaucoup de mal à lutter contre ce qui
fait notre nature et notre individualité
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
aujourd'hui si on veut que l'éco
responsabilité deviennent aussi virale
que netflix que l'iphone il est
fondamental d'utiliser des trois
pouvoirs du design crée des émotions
modifier les comportements et placer
l'humain au centre de toutes les
expériences
grâce au design on peut créer un monde
où chacun s'épanouir trouve du sens dans
sa vie en s'appropriant la démarche
éco-responsable pour en faire la sienne
bref nous avons tous les pouvoirs de
design et pour reprendre une citation
d'une saga qui a vraiment bien compris à
quoi sert le design un grand pouvoir
implique de grandes responsabilités
merci à toutes et à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]